le policier impliqué dans une
altercation avec un citoyen qui a mal
tourné mercredi devant une école
primaire à montréal fait déjà l'objet
d'une autre plainte
ça s'est passé en 2011 il a été cité
dans une affaire de force abusive où il
aurait également utilisé le poivre de
cayenne pour se défendre
normand grover c'est arrivé ici mercredi
vers 17h tout près de l'école au pied de
la montagne
karl cadieux le jeune concierge de
l'établissement a interpellé un policier
qui a grillé un feu rouge sans gyrophare
à l'angle des avenues henri julien et
des pins
quelques minutes plus tard le policier
est revenu sur place lui maudit qui
crisse de bavures pays hypocrite une
poussée avec le doigt fac c'est là que
j'ai décidé de sortir cela j'ai dit tu
agis comme ça on va prendre des vidéos
on sait les relations entre les citoyens
et les policiers peuvent parfois devenir
très tendue dès que les caméras se
braquent sur eux ça le fait sortir de
ses gonds sûrement la vidéo car le cas
du est immédiatement menotté et plaqué
sur le taux de police nadia lessard une
enseignante de sixième a [ __ ] assisté à
toute la scène a tenté d'intervenir
auprès du policier
moi j'ai arrêté près du débat voyons
relaxé c'est pas grave
calmes toi faisait pas mal fils vivent
des femmes ta gueule la conne mais les
affaires y avait pas de m'insulter et le
prix elle par la gorge ici mois par la
gorge ils me jettent la tête dans le
char de police cela la porte était
ouverte je vais entrer dans le champ
puis quand j'étais rendu à sylla et nous
appauvrir les deux j'ai touché le bras
du politique là une fraction de seconde
il me donnait un petit coup comme ceux
qui comme pour bloquer leur apprécié
maintenu à la gorge puis ma pauvre et je
vous jure j'ai vu le prix shaw sortir
même pas d'un pouce de mon visage puis
après je voyais plus rien d'autres
agents sont venus en renfort car le cas
du été conduit au poste de police puis
relâchées sans aucune accusation
nadia l'esa a été accusée elle d'
entrave au travail des policiers
le policier en cause dans cette histoire
fait face à une plainte en déontologie
policière pour un événement survenu en
septembre 2011 sur le boulevard saint
laurent
lester entre autres pour avoir abusé de
son autorité est mal utilisé du poivre
de cayenne
la cause n'est toujours pas terminée le
spvm précise qu'une enquête interne est
déjà en cours qu'est ce qui s'est passé
exactement
je suis en mesure de vous dire
aujourd'hui je peux vous dire que nous
toucher bien ou mal agi je prends le jeu
de le défendre les empêche pas en mesure
de vous dire que benji le spvm s'est
engagée à traiter cette affaire
rapidement
quant aux deux citoyens ils ont
l'intention de déposer une plainte en
déontologie policière
ici normal grondait radio canada
montréal